tommy malone 33 years old it's his
eighth major league club mike he was
having a solid season with the orioles
114 era plus
so he's like it's like tim reigns he
doesn't get caught either what there he
goes he called it and he's got it and
he'll take third and this is what i'm
talking about that pressure right there
alone is why i would like him stealing
more but you talked to some guys mookie
betts is a guy that does not like
getting thrown out so he don't steal as
much as you think he would so the
infield comes in 3-1
back up the middle though smoked
indeed
gloves that
great play thought that was going
through with the infield in there's
austin both
right hander for the nationals
era up around eight got off to a good
start through five shutout innings
against the orioles back on august
eighth he is having a tremendous season
389 on baseline 532 weighted run scooter
plus is 145. in the air
going back and back and it's gone he
thought he missed it
lead off home run
for acuna
just a little bit huh it's effortless so
very rarely have i hit a home run
you know what i missed it the ball goes
out so he slams his bat in anger and
gets a dinger out of it what a pitch a
perfect table set of debris is happening
now here's austin reilly but a lot of
potential and good power
lifted in the air
and josh harrison is there danny
hescherberea
two outs nobody on came back and got him
down the pipe
them out and voth
gets out of trouble and avoids acuna
strikes out malone gets a second
straight strikeout here
by victor robles
and that is a fair ball
bunt single for the lead off man robots
don't see it too often oh that is the
kind of bunt i like okay button for a
hit from a guy who's not necessarily a
strong hitter but he's pretty fast
that's perfect oh and two to kendrick
who slunks over 600 against left-handers
this could be two
and it is tommy malone
dancing through trouble that's the walk
here and here's dansby swanson who is
having a marvelous season offensive puts
this into the air
pretty deep look at this out it goes
dansby swanson two-run shot
easy power for the shortstop sixth home
run of the year
swansea acuna and swanson doing the
damage one two hits balance lets you
know
he's confident you see the hands you see
the balance on the back side and he
stays through that perfect
first pitch swinging again and that ball
is hit deep
yon gom oh whoa
adam duvall and throws it into the plate
a run scores what a play that was a
great play yeah wow and he gets up wow
that's unbelievable and a bomb that was
brought back by adam duvall as ronald
lacuna junior steps up got a home run
and a walk he scored twice that ball is
hit rather well whoa he gave up one into
two back again here you go i think he
heard you
he's he almost crushed that tree
yeah that tree was dunking as it was
coming
all right so he he definitely gave away
a base earlier but he just picked up
four so he's a plus three
a hundred and twelve point six miles per
hour off the bat
smoked to center field and a danger to
the hedges one and two two outs two on
joe west says yes
struck about this is a seven inning game
shane green comes in and i mentioned
having an outstanding season
18 innings era is one 14 strikeouts
and only four walks so shane green comes
on 5-1 ball game green gets the
strikeout for out number one 1-1
to gomes
wicked pitch
and in the air
acuna is there to not go all in or lose
prospects
for this year real quick would you have
given up christian pache for lancelin
one two
into right field and drops in for the
base hit from the taylor what roon will
score
another one
[Applause]
taylor took a look bobbled and it was
too late and the braves have a 7-1 lead
i know it's been tough on the nas this
year but that type of play you harp on
negativity all the time i get it but
michael taylor knows he has to glove
that ball
out away
turn to push that into center field
and ronald acount
with his two home runs
will end this ballgame appropriately
great play by cuny in this game great
play as well by adam duvall brian
snidker and his club have won
five in a row